Hi, my name is Howard Forman.
I'm a physician and a professor
at the Yale School of Public
Health and Yale
School of Management.
I'd like to talk about one
method of protecting people
from COVID-19 that's been
getting some attention,
herd immunity.
In simple terms, herd immunity
is communal protection from
a disease, we achieve it
once a large proportion of a
population is immune to the
disease and presumably the
ability to spread
it. Dramatically reducing the
risk of spread to
others who are not immune.
You can think of it as the
percentage of a population that
must be immune
to extend immunity
to others automatically.
The safest way to
do this is through vaccination.
Through vaccines,
we have achieved herd immunity
to many dangerous diseases,
including measles,
whooping cough and chicken pox.
Isolated incidents can
still occur, but it means a
major outbreak
is highly unlikely.
Before vaccines herd immunity
was achieved naturally
but brutally.
Disease would
spread unchecked,
survivors would develop
antibodies and immunity.
Eventually, enough people would
be immune to halt spread until
new unimmunized members of
society were introduced
generally via
birth or migration,
and then outbreaks
could occur again.
In the case of the virus that
causes covid-19, achieving herd
immunity without a vaccine
would require allowing up to 70
percent of the US population
to become infected.
That's two hundred and thirty
one million people.
And since zero point four
percent of those individuals at
the lowest estimate would die,
we would lose close to one
million Americans and leave
countless others with
longstanding health problems.
This violates a central tenet
of biomedical ethics:
To achieve herd immunity to
COVID-19 through vaccination,
a substantial percent of the
population must be vaccinated,
perhaps as high as
70 percent of those eligible.
through patience and by
employing various strategies to
manage COVID-19's spread,
including: